[Music]
the urgings Dwight from the Royal
Society summer science exhibition and
here's a little taste of what we'll be
bringing you on this week's show Alex
looks at what could be a virtual reality
solution for anxiety while I step into
the world of forensics with some
revealing new software and our games
reviewers got what he says might just be
his favorite title of the year
welcome to Skype from what is the oldest
scientific academy and continued its
existence
here at the Royal Society they've been
running their summer science exhibition
all week bringing together some of the
country's best researchers and Alex has
already been getting hands-on with some
of the exhibits here he is with a
digital project as going to help people
deal with mental health problems
so I bet you've tracked your footsteps
or monitored your heart rate or counted
your calories and if you haven't you
know someone who has
so from wearables to smartphones when it
comes to our tech our physical health is
covered but when was the last time you
checked in with your thoughts your
feelings anxieties well researchers are
now using virtual reality to help
children cope with anxiety so at the
moment how we've designed it it's just
for assessment purposes so it's just to
get an idea of how young people feel in
social situations but our plan is to
develop this canteen environment into a
therapy so for children who have
particularly anxious and social
situations and we can then over session
over
therapeutic sessions whether with a
psychologist we can slowly minute we can
manipulate the environment to increase
the level of stress somebody's just told
me that I can't sit next to him and he's
put his bag on the chair so obviously
this is the kind of thing that could
happen in a canteen I mean it seems
particularly mean because there are lots
of spare chairs but so some young people
will perceive it as quite hostile that
the kids are other people sort of
interpreted okay he is genuine genuinely
waiting for someone and don't feel
threatened by it at all so if you wanted
to measure the same thing in real life
you can't control the environment in
exactly the same way for each for each
young person so with virtual reality you
can put them in realistic situations and
give everyone exactly the same
experience and then you can look at the
differences in how in how they how they
feel how they interpret those those
interactions so first of all I find a
worry that I'm having I tap on the
bubble if virtual reality can help in
therapy the team believe a smartphone
app could help in well reality as in
when worries arise I passed me to slow
down to worry so I tap on the spinning
and worry bubble this is encouraging me
to take a moment to think the worry
through do you see some others replacing
the conventional therapist and we're
doing so much she is replacing the
conventional therapist but it's a way of
really helping to improve access to
psychological therapies we know that
there's
enough supply at the moment to meet the
need and the demand so for this kind of
tech to really take off there need to be
a shift in the way we all see our mental
health from something we only look at
when there's a problem something we keep
track of in our daily lives but demand
for help is high and resources are
stretched so it's an interesting idea
that the tech we already have around us
could put a therapist in our pocket it's
something you can't fit in your pocket
stay with us because still to come I'll
be finding out how much information a
footprint from my old trainers can
reveal about me with some new forensic
science software that's coming right up
after a roundup of this week's tech news
Volvo is on course to be the first
mainstream car manufacturer to produce
only electric or hybrid vehicles from
2019 all of its models will have an
electric motor also this week American
firm Tesla announced its first
mass-market electric car the model 3
will go on sale later this month after
passing regulatory requirements schools
have issued warnings about a recent
location sharing feature on snapchat
which it's feared could potentially be
exposing children to stalkers it allows
users to see where their friends are on
a map the company has stressed though
that snap map is an opt-in feature you
won't be pinpointed unless you switch it
on lovely and we've got an update on how
human like sex robots could impact
society the Foundation for Responsible
robotics suggests the Box could
potentially provide a service for
disabled or elderly people as well as be
used for entertainment but it's warned
the revolution could also be dangerous
stick around for our games review in
just a few minutes we've got a fantasy
card game spin off but before that now
one of the exhibits that's really caught
my eye here is one that linked dinosaurs
to modern-day criminals is also do with
footprint analysis that's a Matthew
Bennet can tell us a bit more and it's
an all about software that you come up
with it is so over the years we've
studied fossil footprints dinosaurs
ancient humans we did lots of software
to help us analyze it and we've
translated that and for use by the
police and forensic services recently
here that we'll take a picture or an
impression of the soldier your feet and
that's the first step
in analyzing footwear evidence now I'm
wearing a pair of my oldest trainers
because I heard you can get a better
reading from an older pair of trainers
is that true that's true you stand on
the on the scanner and then walk forward
placing one foot in in there and the
picture appears here at the instant so
that's the the sole of your trainers
very very distinctive I know you said
they were old but they're not that old
because you can still see very nice
tread patterns on them but also and you
can begin to see fairly these thinking
patterns of wear where everybody walks
different and because we're all built
slightly differently and that is
manifesting the way our soles of our
shoes wear down in different pants quite
quite this thing too and the soft way
you've been working on is even more
advanced and you can make them into 3d
images yes 3d the key thing is that at
the moment at a crime scene if it's a
really important crime scene they'd
still be using technology there's
hundred years old they'll be putting
plaster into the track and casting it
but what we're able to do is taking 20
additional photographs with a normal
digital camera
and it takes about a minute and a half
of extra time at the crime scene bring
that back and within three or four
minutes and of processing you're able to
create a digital model light like that
one and how much more information can
this tell you compared to the
traditional way that the police we use
okay well what we've just scanned your
trainers was two-dimensional this is
three-dimensional information which
gives you a lot of information about the
tread details they depth diffusion tells
you about weight distribution on the
person the biomechanics of the
individual and when you've gone and look
at one or two other things in the in the
software you can begin to compare
different shoes how difficult was it to
come up with the computer science behind
it because you're a geologist I am but I
can visualize the problem and I can talk
to the coders think that the computer
science experts to actually build and
blend different things and we write a
bit ourselves but we also use a lot of
open source code an open source code is
community code that's developed by
people working in their back bedrooms to
the love of coding and as a community
project they develop little algorithms
to do some really cool things video
games time now in this weekend yeah
period with his pickup latest releases
Ghana is a side-scrolling shooter that
everyone is saying is roguelike because
basically what that means is you die a
lot well that's kind of the point of it
because you are actually helping out
death so you're going around the place
shooing things and the idea is that if
you're good enough des is gonna give you
back a life of your friend Sally who's a
giant space whale it's pretty weird but
it looks lovely and to be fair even
though I didn't really played on steam
force which it's absolutely perfect
because it's a love your handheld thing
that when you get annoyed with it you
can put it down go back to it and then
maybe take a little bit of time go have
another go and you might be better
that's it as I said if you didn't play
on Steam switch is the perfect way to
play this game
so remember fable the slightly naughty
RPG that had a really really silly
British sense of humor because it was
made by British developers Lionhead well
when that studio got shut down a couple
of developers left with the fable
license and they decided to sort of make
a game in the same vein as fable but
instead of being an RPG it's a
collectible card game it's actually
really good
lay a lot of people sort of compared it
to half stone in that kind of way that
it's gonna be a competitive card game I
never really got into hearthstone
because it was really really hard but
there's something about fable is a
little bit more inviting
I don't a--first the fact that it's a
co-op game so if you can find someone
who's better than you they kind of like
rub on for you a little bit even if you
have never played a card game before
it's gonna hit early access food and
then it's gonna be free-to-play so might
as well I'm going
I generally think Friday the 13th on the
PlayStation 4 is gonna be up there with
one of my games of the year it's
basically you as a counselor in the
world of fire 13th or as Jaison buries
the naughty guy in Friday 13th and you
have two different jobs as the counselor
your job is to escape or to stop Jason
by a bunch of very different means to
all a multiplayer game all online and
it's got this amazing thing on it which
is like closed circuits and chat so the
chat is is always on but you'll only
hear people if they're close to you so
as you're walking around like searching
for you know weapons to try and kill
Jason or car keys or car battery or
something like that if one of your
somebody comes close to you that's when
you can hear them talking like what you
doing and in a similar way Jason can
then hear you if he's close to you but
it's brilliant it's really fun if you
die but it's also really fun if you go
away and there's not many games there's
fun to play even if you're dying I think
so you should definitely have a go on
that well that's it for this week's show
but don't forget to follow us on Twitter
why hello there behind this thing stuff
throughout the week I'll be back next
week I hope you can join us then bye-bye
you
[Music]